-Performing "Last Night Lonely"
from his upcoming new album,
"Mr. Saturday Night,"
please welcome Jon Pardi!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yeah, this could be your last
drink from a stranger in a bar ♪
♪ The last time that you're
dancin' in unfamiliar arms ♪
♪ Yeah, this could be
your last first kiss ♪
♪ If we do this thing right ♪
♪ Your last time alone
beneath neon lights ♪
♪ It could be your last night
comin' in here ♪
♪ Drinkin' all by yourself ♪
♪ The last time givin' your
heart away to someone else ♪
♪ Yeah, we could be some history
in the makin', girl ♪
♪ Tonight might be
your last night lonely ♪
♪♪
♪ Yeah, you could be
the last first name ♪
♪ That's ever been
worth askin' ♪
♪ Yeah, you could be
the last phone number ♪
♪ I write down on a napkin ♪
♪ Yeah, you could be
the last girl ♪
♪ That I take
back home to mama ♪
♪ The last time that we're
talked about ♪
♪ In this small town drama ♪
♪ It's gonna be the last night
comin' in here ♪
♪ Drinkin' all by yourself ♪
♪ The last time givin' your
heart away to someone else ♪
♪ Yeah, we could be some history
in the makin', girl ♪
♪ Tonight might be
your last night lonely ♪
♪ It could be your ♪
♪ Last night lonely ♪
♪♪
♪ It's gonna be the last time
comin' in here ♪
♪ Drinkin' all by yourself ♪
♪ The last time givin' your
heart away to someone else ♪
♪ Yeah, we could be some history
in the makin', girl ♪
♪ Tonight might be
your last night lonely ♪
♪ It could be your last night
comin' in here ♪
♪ Drinkin' all by yourself ♪
♪ The last time givin' your
heart away to someone else ♪
♪ Yeah, we could be some history
in the makin', girl ♪
♪ Tonight might be
your last night lonely ♪
♪ It could be
♪♪
♪ Last night lonely, baby ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]